here it is on lance mccullers
to try and split this series we talked
about that last start against the
dodgers
stepping up in a big way going six and
two-thirds shutout baseball looking to
build upon that performance
ground ball to shore two big hops for
correa lance
pumps his fists into his glove as he
likes what he saw in that first inning
he threw
every pitch for a strike but won the
starting pitcher stats for
kenta maeda on the hill for the twins
tonight that'll be a pass ball
charged to garver allowing mccormick to
move into scoring position
reaches out pops one up shallow right
trouble so no
can't quite make the play brantley's
gonna have to hustle to second
the throw goes wide to second in the
score mccormick
simmons knocks brantley down
and that could be interference
but right now brantley stays at second
the astros get a run
right now i'm just hoping brantley's
okay because simmons got into him pretty
good as this ball got
heavy behind sono who got a glove on it
but was unable to make the catch
tough read for michael brantley who was
going back and forth in between second
and first
that was where the closest play was and
that's why polanco came up
surveyed made the throw but you can see
that left elbow
going into the face of michael brantley
as simmons came down on him
two quick outs here in the second and
now cave
and a fair ball down the line good bad
for cave that'll
slowly bounce to second base and that'll
allow cave to round second try for third
and he's in there with a triple great to
see
jk fighting off some two strike pitches
working the count full and ending up at
third base here is
larnick with the tying run at third
dunk behind third and a base head cave
comes in to score the tying run
and larnick getting a breaking ball
in the zone and dumping it to left for
an rbi single michael brantley who took
an elbow or an arm to the head on a play
at second base
from angelson simmons is not on deck
right now you scheduled to bat third in
this inning but jake
myers looks like he will pinch hit for
the designated hitter brantley
twins could do with the lead off walk so
no struck out on three pitches
now he was ready for it and he lifts it
high and deep to left field
good bye up by the train tracks
so they went back to the well once too
often
good for miguel cino went up there
finally looking for a breaking ball
that's
he's been seeing just such a steady diet
of those and everything about that at
bat was
best that we've seen in quite a while
for miguel cino
maeda on the mound with the twins
leading 3-1
drive the other way larnick back at the
wall looks up
and it's off the top of the wall and
bounds away
jordan hustles to second goes in sliding
with a double
jordan didn't miss putting one in the
crawford boxes by
much ends up with a one out double
[Music]
no but he did where he missed
on the prior pitch he clipped the
outside corner for strike three
two down
the other way diving is temp by polanco
throw in time to get jones what a play
by polanco
the inning is over but the
twins weren't sure and ceno threw home
just in case but jones
was called out at first base
we're gonna get a better look at it here
does jones beat it looks like he might
oh yes what tk so the play will hold
it'll be a 3-2 game
there we go
but that was a phenomenal play by
polanco great hustle by jones and you
could see the immediate reaction from
ceno was that the brunner was safe at
first i've got to get the runner at home
plate
there was not even there was no
hesitation from snow
and then ceno's throw goes past the
catcher garber allowing tucker to get to
third
how about jordan running right through
omar lopez right there
forcing that play at home plate
there's the safe call yep they put
everybody right where they're supposed
to go colors will
face polanco garber in a rise here in
the twins fifth
polanco lifts it to left field alvarez
is back looking up
and it's gone to left field and see
polanco hit too many to the opposite
field
but in houston that works exactly right
he gets a fast ball away
is trying to after being getting behind
one and all trying to hit the outside
corner
palaqua just goes with it and in this
ballpark that plays
astros with two runners on and one out
in the fifth inning down four to two
ground ball towards short simmons to
polanco for
one and the throw will be not able to be
handled by ceno
so safe at first will be diaz looked
like it was a double play ground ball
that ball's roped past polanco into
right field
rbi single by jordan alvarez rbi number
74 on the year
and the astros back within a run it's
four to three
looks like a hanging split
jordon wanted to do a little bit more
with it he put a thump
behind this one ripping it past polanco
in the right field for that rbi base hit
with two outs
could have been more with a little bit
more of a launch angle 110.5 miles an
hour
simmons catches the one-hop smash it was
a breaking ball it worked
rooker is taking a walk that's a nice
one for the twins to get because it sets
up polanco with two men on base
and a high fly to right field way
back and gone
number 20 for polanco and the twins
break it open hanging breaking ball
right in the middle of the zone
and the hottest and best hitter on the
twins club comes through again
[Applause]
home runs 19 and 20 today for polanco
number 20 a big one with a couple of men
aboard left-hander blake taylor
making his 30-second appearance
fastball rolled up the middle for a base
hit
and arise keeps picking up hits in
clusters
busted bat put a base hit to left and
the rise will check in at second base
ball four and they're loaded up with one
out
got that call on the edge larnick out on
strikes
papa playable taylor jones
right near the foul line puts it away
for the final out of the inning two down
base is empty
and now myers hits that ball hard into
right center field jake
myers has his first major league hit one
hops against the fence congratulations
jake myers
a two out double the other way
it's gonna feel great for jake myers
getting that first big league hit
diaz shoots one to right field that'll
be all the way to the wall off the top
of the wall
in the score myers to second oledmiss
sliding with an rbi
doubles now a 7-4 game
it's not too often we see it led miss
diaz going the other way but he picked a
good pitch to do it on and this will
give you an idea of how close it
actually was hitting just below that
yellow line in right field
jake myers getting his first hit first
run scored on that rocket to right field
off the bat of the lead miss
carlos correa kyle tucker and taylor
jones do
up the correa drives one
deep to left line drive home run carlos
correa
home run number 18 on the air astros
within two
it's 7-5
[Applause]
trying to get in underneath the hands
and carlos drops the barrel on it
and leaves no doubt about it at 106.8
miles an hour off the bat
wow they're three outs away from taking
three out of four against the division
leading houston astros
polanco flips and snow stretches to end
the ball game
the longest road trip of the year for
the twins
arguably the best road trip of the year
for the twins as they'll come home
with a five and four mark
you